c'est sur son compte instagram qu'alexei
navalni annoncé dans une vidéo
son retour en russie un retour planifié
pour ce dimanche 17 janvier via une
compagnie aérienne russe low cost qui
dessert l'allemagne l'opposant qui
prétend que vladimir poutine a
personnellement commandité son
assassinat estime que les autorités font
tout ce qu'elles peuvent pour empêcher
qu'il revienne en russie et c'est
notamment une peine de prison ferme qui
pourrait l'attendre à son retour à
moscou en effet alexeï navalni a été
condamné à trois ans et demi de prison
avec sursis en 2014 pour détournement de
fonds et dans le cadre de cette affaire
la période probatoire à laquelle il
était soumis avait été prolongé jusqu'à
la fin de l'année 2020 ils s'exposent
donc théoriquement à une peine de prison
ferme s'il est jugé qu' alexeï navalni
n'a pas respecté les conditions de son
sursis en ne retournant pas
immédiatement en russie après sa
convalescence passé en allemagne
attendons maintenant dimanche tout
d'abord pour voir si l'opposant
effectuera bien le voyage prévu et le
cas échéant observer la réaction des
autorités à son retour sur le sol russe